apavou alors la mort de la mort c'est un
livre de laurent alexandre bien sûr je
les ai oubliés puisque je me suis
réinventer refabriquer et comme vous
n'êtes pas mis la cia ni la police est
ni un détective je vous dirais que je
m'appelle orlan or blanc et mon nom
s'écrit chaque lettres en majuscules
parce que je ne veux pas rentrer dans
les rangs je ne veux pas qu'on me fasse
rentrer dans la ligne mais bien sûr
l'art commence bien avant la chirurgie
jeu je suis pas c'est pas mon job de
faire de la chirurgie je suis une
artiste et c'est toutes les oeuvres
précédentes qui m'ont conduit à faire
cette oeuvre qui étaient en fait les
journaux on dit beaucoup beaucoup de
bêtises et les télés mais c'était
simplement pour attaquer l'image de
l'ine le masque de l'inné et en faire
autre chose et surtout utilisé la
chirurgie à contre courant en la
déréglant et en faisant des gestes
opératoires qui n'étaient pas censés
apporter de la beauté mais au contraire
de tout ce qui serait du côté de
l'handicap et qu'il ne me rendrais pas
sereine bien sûr je ne le ferai pas je
travaille avec les possibles avec la
faisabilité actuel de ce que l'on peut
faire sur un corps sans en souffrir
parce que ma première demande ou
chirurgiens étaient pas de douleur ni
avant ni pendant ni après je pense que
c'est que chacun fait ce qu'il veut avec
les possibles de son époque mais moi je
suis ni technophiles ni technophobes ce
que j'aime c'est vivre intensément mon
époque
mais bien sûr toujours avec une distance
critique donc ce que j'ai fait c'est
quelque chose bien sûr de critiques
[Musique]
elle n'existe pas on tourne toujours
autour et puis je n'ai jamais cherché la
perfection j'ai cherché à fabriquer une
image supplémentaire autre deux mois
[Musique]
mais écoutez il faut signer ma pétition
contre la mort et il n'y aura aucun
problème je serai immortels comme vous
tous et vous tout mais effectivement la
lama pétition contre la mort pour moi
extrêmement importante parce que c'est
vraiment quand même une saloperie total
grave que tout le monde a accepté on
baisse les bras d'ailleurs la religion
elle nous a fait accepter qu
effectivement on devait mourir mais moi
je n'ai rien fait de mal je vois pas
pourquoi je suis condamné à mort quand
on aura compris comment fonctionne leur
horloge biologique
tout ça sera transformé moi je voudrais
vivre autant de temps que les séquoias
géants qui vivent de 3005 4005 5000 ans
donc là vraiment on a tiré la conte
paille les humains il faut vraiment
changer ça il faut améliorer ça il faut
transformer ça
[Musique]